max arbeitet auf der intensivstation die
arbeitsbedingungen im krankenhaus machen
ihn sorgen ich wünsche mir dass ich
meine lieben hinten krankenhaus bringen
kann ohne angst haben zu müssen dass sie
schlecht und zu wenig versorgt sein weil
ich mir bewusst bin dass viele patienten
hier legen und bedürfnisse haben die
nicht von einer person mit 20 betten
erfüllt das geht nicht durch bewohner
sind viele intensivstation überfüllt
doch der druck auf das personal war
schon vor der panini hoch und auch jetzt
wieder mit krone
gesehen was mit diesem problem wir
eigentlich ja mal kurzzeitig habe mir
alle so ein kleines euphorische dachten
okay jetzt ändert sich was jetzt die
gesellschaft einsehen da läuft einfach
was grundlegend schief und nach zwei
monaten weil das alles wieder verpufft
das macht mich wütend also es macht mich
wütend es macht mich traurig und das
macht also auch also kein spaß aber
warum ist das eigentlich alles so ich
will verstehen woher die hohe
arbeitsbelastung in vielen deutschen
krankenhäusern kommt und warum viele
mitarbeitende so frustriert und
verunsichert sind
[Musik]
die situation für viele menschen in
gesundheitsberufen ist fordernd und
belastend in diesem video spreche ich
aber speziell mit assistenz ärzten und
ärztinnen sie stehen nämlich noch am
anfang ihrer ausbildung zum facharzt
erfolg in der mainzer uniklinik treffe
ich dr max benkendorf der sich mir als
max vorstellt erst hier assistenzarzt im
dritten jahr und möchte facharzt der
anästhesie werden gerade arbeitet er auf
der intensivstation und ich darf ihn
mehr seiner spätschicht begleiten was
uns heute alles auf station erwartet und
wie sein arbeitstag aussieht das konnte
mir max nicht sagen da jeder tag hier
irgendwie anders ist manchmal ist genug
zeit so eine ausführliche visite aber
oft startet der tag auch einfach schon
mit herausforderungen dann ist es
wichtig schnell zu priorisieren alle
patienten und patientinnen werden
natürlich untersucht wir dürfen nicht
bei allen untersuchungen mit dabei sein
aber bei dieser hier schon eine
persönliche ansprache und sich so gut es
geht zeit nehmen dass es max sehr
wichtig obwohl das leider nicht immer
möglich ist
hallo wir sind wieder da sind auf der
intensivstation
ich mache einmal die augen auch nicht
erschrecken hallo
haben sie schmerzen nein ein bisschen
müde das kommt noch von der op wo man
sich keine sorgen machen keine angst
haben passen gut auf sie auf ja
wird einmal kalt nicht erschrecken
letztendlich die
die ganze patientin von oben bis unten
an das sind dann sehen wer einmal einen
eindruck verschafft von allen patienten
der ableitenden systeme dass man
letztendlich nichts übersieht
einmal gucke ich mir natürlich die also
patienten an ich kenne sie auch schon
von gestern und jetzt von der übergabe
macht mir selber ein bild und überprüft
dann noch mal was es zu tun gibt in der
kurve und schreibt praktisch alles das
was mir auffällt hier sozusagen ein alle
unterlagen bereit machen das eben für
alle patienten je nachdem was ansteht
also was kann davon ab das ist sozusagen
die arbeit ja das muss man alles ordnen
und dann sich überlegen was ist jetzt im
moment das wichtigste pauli in einem
anderen zimmer ist natürlich so dass wir
die patientin wasser werden lassen und
gegebenenfalls später den
beatmungsschlauch ziehen aber dafür muss
ich erst also feststellen dass die
situation in einen anderen zu machen
stabil ist dann würde ich mich wenn
etwas passiert auf die konzentrieren
kann
für mich war diese untersuchungen eine
besondere erfahrung hier geht es einfach
um menschenleben ich weiß nicht ob ich
mit diesem druck umgehen könnte genau
das infiziert für max ist das aber der
alltag wichtig für seine spätschicht ist
die gemeinsame visite mit seinem
stellvertretenden oberarzt dr fehle
lindemann die beiden machen eine
übergabe von arzt zu arzt und tauschen
sich über alle patienten und
patientinnen aus gefahr bei den
übergaben ist natürlich immer dass
informationen verloren gehen das müssen
wir vermeiden dadurch dass wir das jeden
tag machen versucht man das so gut als
möglich zu machen aber und das macht er
immer eine stunde zusammen und also
wieder zeit haben wenn irgendwas krieger
ist dann muss man halt kurz
sozusagen gestalten oder
noch ist es ruhig auf der
intensivstation war die übergabe ja noch
einmal durch das was hier passiert
passiert sofort gut dass es so dass das
nicht planbar ist es gibt schichten da
ist es so dass man abends die pleite
geht dann stellt einmal auf das man gar
nicht auf toilette war und dann fällt an
meinen stimmt mal die ausgedrückt aber
gerade für die juden assistenten in den
ersten monaten ist es so dass hier immer
einfach dinge rund um basieren und sie
wissen nicht wieso das sind dann eben
assistenzärzte auf den weg zum vater hat
die hier einigermaßen die abläufe kennen
und auch einigermaßen arbeiten können
das sind ganz ganz weiter weg bis man
wirklich sich auf einer intensivstation
an stimmt wohl zu fühlen
absolut ist es so dass man sich erst mal
fragen kann was kann ich überhaupt
entscheiden was nicht fehlt mir da
erfahrungen vielleicht auch und das ist
schon so dass jetzt nach den ersten
monaten nicht sagen muss
dass diese berührungspunkte mit
invasiven maßnahmen
hochtechnologisierten berufsumfeld und
wahnsinnig viel emotionen von allen
seiten also herausfordernd ist aber
ich glaube manchmal
hilft das auch also mit erfahrenen
kolleginnen zu sprechen die einem dann
zur seite stehen sagt mach dir keinen
kopf das war vielleicht nicht richtig
mir ging es am anfang auch so und diese
emotional vielleicht auch kollegial der
anteilnahme daran dass es für den moment
schwer ist und das verständnis dass es
schwer ist und dass man auch sich gehört
wird und gesagt hey das ist jetzt noch
nicht stimmt dann muss das jetzt
vielleicht das ist noch nicht stimmen
dass derzeit watt ab es wird besser das
gibt einem halt
letztlich die speziellen erfahrungen die
man gemacht
und er hat natürlich vollkommen recht
wenn man persönlich das als team
abzufangen und dann auch irgendwelche
strategien hat jemand hält sich als
kopie geht dann ist das letztlich ein
rettungsring natürlich ist es so dass
wenn man da nicht aufpasst hab ich muss
weiter nach der visite mit den allgemein
tieren ist max der betreuende arzt für
seinen bereich unterstützt bitte durch
das pflegepersonal und einen
stellvertretende oberärztin ist bei
notfällen telefonisch zu erreichen eine
to do liste ist voll dokumentieren
laborwerte checken opis vorbereiten sich
mit allen absprechen und auf keinen fall
die patienten und patientinnen aus den
augen lassen die müssen gerade auf
intensiv ständig überwacht und
untersucht werden notfälle können
natürlich immer dazwischen kommen ich
hatte max das alles in seiner schicht
adler immer viel zurück im schichtdienst
lässt sich das gar nicht vermeiden ich
denke es gibt immer dinge zu tun immer
dinge sagt das muss noch mal nachlesen
das muss ich noch mal so ich
kapitulieren manchmal passieren einem
auch also letztendlich
dein moment
danach
kann ich gleich zurückrufen fünf minuten
perfekt danke tschüss
ja das war meine stellvertreter
oberärztin die letztendlich auch mal an
mit guckt und der ich dann
klagen wo man denken auf andere sehr
intensiv auf das alles irgendwie ganz
schön stressig max versucht alle to do's
abzuarbeiten überall den überblick zu
behalten ständig piepst ein monitor im
hintergrund und jederzeit könnte ein
notfall passieren für mich wäre der
druck glaube ich nichts ich bin jetzt
seit einigen stunden mit max auf
stationen der macht seinen beruf echt
aus leidenschaft aber der druck ist auch
für ihn auf jeden fall hoch als ich für
dieses thema angefangen habe zu
recherchieren habe ich gemerkt dass er
damit nicht alleine ist eine studie des
marburger bunds mit 6500 angestellten
krankenhaus ärzten und ärztinnen zeigt
dass knapp die hälfte häufig überlastet
ist jede und jeder zehnte gibt an dass
sie ständig über ihre seine grenzen geht
über genau das spreche ich auch mit den
bunten kitteln das ist eine kampagne von
jungen menschen aus einem
gesundheitsberufen seit frühjahr 2020
demonstrieren sie und werden laut gegen
das aktuelle system ihre vision ein
gesundheitssystem bei dem der mensch
wieder im fokus steht
frustrierend also ich würde sagen dass
schon ein großer teil der kolleginnen
und kollegen er regelmäßig darüber
nachdenkt zu kündigen und dann ist aber
immer die frage was mache ich dann mit
diesen beruf eigentlich ausmacht dieser
beruf selber ja spaß aber ich sehe
eigentlich auch keine möglichkeit dass
es irgendwo anders besser werden weil
die arbeitsbedingungen überall ähnlich
schlecht sind und das ist auch nicht
also da kann man doch dann die einzelnen
krankenhäusern keinen vorwurf machen
weil sie einfach nicht anders können das
system ist cool sie vorgibt das system
davon ist oft die rede wenn es um unsere
gesundheitsversorgung geht doch was ist
eigentlich dieses system viel kritik
gibt es an dem diagnosis related groups
ist das sogenannte fallpauschalensystem
wurde 2003 ursprünglich eingeführt und
verweildauer im krankenhaus zu senken
seit 2004 werden unsere krankenhäuser
darüber finanziert konkret bedeutet das
dass krankenhäuser für jede
patientenbehandlung einen pauschalen
betrag von der krankenkasse
zurückerstattet bekommen den
fallpauschalen katalog sind alle
krankheiten und die dazugehörigen
behandlungen gelistet mit einer art
preisschild versehen die pauschalen
werden jährlich neu kalkuliert kommt ein
patient oder eine patientin ins
krankenhaus wird er oder sie abhängig
von der diagnose einer fallpauschale
zugeordnet ein beispiel diagnose
blinddarmentzündung die pauschale gibt
den preis die passende behandlung und
die verweildauer im krankenhaus vor eine
blinddarmentzündung ohne komplikationen
wird mit zirka 3000 euro erlöst vergütet
das problem dabei die menschen sind
individuelle wesen und deswegen verläuft
auch nicht bei jedem oder jeder jede
krankheit gleich und schon gar nicht wie
es der katalog vorsieht zurück zu
blinddarmentzündung das system
berücksichtigt zum beispiel nicht ob ich
mit 27 jahren erkrankt führen oder mein
82-jähriger oper bräuchte mein opa mehr
zeit zum gesundwerden und müsste länger
im krankenhaus bleiben als es die
pauschale vorsieht ist das gar nicht so
einfach die klinik bekommt nicht nur den
vorgesehenen pauschalen betrag und nicht
die tatsächlichen kosten zurückerstattet
jeder tag länger würde also verluste für
das krankenhaus bedeuten dadurch
entsteht ein hoher wirtschaftlicher
druck auf das medizinische personal und
der gedanke dass man mit krankheiten
gewinne erzielen muss dagegen wehrt sich
nadia rakowitz vom verein demokratischer
ärztinnen und ärzte der berufsverband
kritisiert dass die edi system scharf
das ist
drastischer eingriff auch in ärztliche
professionelles ethos dass das führt
dann zu burn outs zu alle möglichen
formen das zu verarbeiten die unschönen
sinn für alle beteiligten für
krankenhäuser ist der ökonomische druck
kein problem sie stehen dadurch
unfreiwillig im wettbewerb und sind
somit auch wirtschaftsunternehmen
krankenhäuser die nicht kostendeckend
arbeiten können dann im schlimmsten fall
dicht gemacht werden nadia rakowitz
erzählt mir dass alle medizinischen
fachrichtungen davon betroffen sind
einige rentieren sich wirtschaftlich
gesehen aber wohl besonders wenig das
ist zum beispiel in der uniklinik
rostock gibt es jetzt ein brandbrief von
von den ärzten dort die sagen wir können
keine adäquate kinder medizinische
versorgung mehr machen
intensivmedizinischer
weil das so kaputt gespart ist diese
debatte ist echt ziemlich komplex aber
was bedeutet das konkret für das
krankenhauspersonal
für viele geht es hier ja um 14
berufsethos denn der wirtschaftliche
druck hat ja auch eine auswirkung auf
die patientenversorgung bei max und
raffaele auf der intensivstation erlebe
ich die versorgung der patienten und
patientinnen mit bei einer patientin
soll heute der beatmungsschlauch
entfernt werden das nennt man
exploration
eine indikationserweiterung
lässt
sich nämlich sagen ob die
demonstrations- person möglich mitmachen
ein grund warum sich der gas austauschen
so dass matthias schubert einzige kunde
ist ja der dass diese bei jeder so weit
ist die maxime
fest und deswegen diesmal wieder schnell
wie das nirgendwo gegangen
und ich würde da jetzt ehrlich gesagt
mal sturzflug landes versuchen sogar
schon vorbereitet dass man dann den
rückwärtsgang wieder einschalten kann
ich guck mal dieser zeit nicht stehen
ist jetzt halt mir
fehlen noch vier bis dahin werde ich
alles versuchen
bei der behandlung können wir nicht mit
dabei sein wenn hier etwas schiefgehen
würde würden wir einfach im weg herum
stehen der beatmungsschlauch konnte an
diesem tag nicht mehr in max schicht
entfernt werden ich will wissen spielt
auch bei so lebens entscheidenden
behandlungen wie auf der intensivstation
das wirtschaftliche system eine rolle
und wie ist das schaut euch da jemand
auf der finger
also ich bin hier heute nachmittag heute
allein und ich bediene mich anhand derer
also werde ich meine möglichkeiten die
mir hier geboten würden natürlich ist es
so dass wir auch also nachrichten
bekommen klinikinternen die sagen bevor
ihr dieses bronchoskopie einmal
verwendet gucken dass ihr mehrfach
bronchitis gruppe verwendet weil die
einfach also nur zehn prozent der kosten
kosten ja wenn das aber nicht da ist
weil es aus dem story nicht zurückkommt
und man hat mir kurz situation beim
patienten mit einem keim da überlege ich
nicht ob das 250 euro kostet das auf
druck da rein und versucht das problem
zu lösen und auch wenn dann die
nachricht kommt das rechnet sich nicht
oder das ist zu teuer das ist mir in dem
moment egal ob gerade in der
intensivmedizin es ist einfach so dass
was wir hier tun ist teuer und wenn man
eben diesen maßstab anlegt an ein
gesundheitssystem das soll schwarze
zahlen schreiben dann ist die
intensivmedizinische sicherheit der
falsche ort um zu gucken weil da ist es
immer ein treuer gast und zwar arbeiten
was für dich wir versorgen patienten und
wir versuchen nicht profitorientiert zu
sein sondern versuchen das zu machen was
notwendig ist und die gesellschaft gibt
uns vor wie das gesundheitssystem sein
soll dass man das profit orientiert sein
oder sollen das individuelle medizin
sein zu den negativen folgen des drg
systems wurde auch schon geforscht
professor doktor wegkamp hat untersucht
welche auswirkungen gewinn orientierte
medizin auf die patientenversorgung hat
und was das mit dem medizinischen
personal macht das führt zu vielen
unterschiedlichen konsequenzen sei es
patienten dann entlassen werden sollen
wenn sie nicht mehr profitabel sind sei
es das nicht profitable oder
möglicherweise nur sehr aufwändig
begründbare therapie hin kaum noch
möglich sind schließlich haben wir noch
beobachtet und mehrfach gehört dass sich
die ärztinnen und ärzte genötigt fühlen
sogenannte kreative
diagnosen zu stellen das heißt patienten
so einzuordnen und dass sie möglichst
hochpreisig am ende berechnet werden
können er erzählt mir dass ich dadurch
das berufsbild und der charakter der
medizin stark verändert hat junge ärzte
und ärztinnen und die pflege sind
unmittelbar von dieser tatsache
betroffen gerade junge ärzte in
aufnahmesituationen und auch in
notfallsituationen
geradezu
traumatisierende belastungen hinein
geraten weil kein keine oberärztin kein
oberarzt und clanchefs vorhanden ist um
in hilfe zu geben auch nadia rakowitz
spricht von enormen auswirkungen auf
ärzte und ärztinnen das krankenhaus hat
sich eine fabrik verband macht irgendwie
der fließbandarbeit möglichst wenig
sprechen mit den patienten prozeduren
durchziehen ja weil das das ökonomische
wichtige ist alles was ökonomisch nicht
wichtig ist fällt hinten und
kann das so in zukunft weiter gehen nein
fordern die bunten kittel bei ihren
protesten und unserer meinung nach muss
dass ich einfach grundsätzlich ändern
dass wir einen kosten decken das
abrechnungssystem bekommen
wo die notwendigen sachen die beiden
patientinnen gemacht werden müssen auch
wieder rückerstattet werden oder bezahlt
werden so dass die arbeit nicht mehr
anhand von wirtschaftlichen faktoren
stattfindet sondern wirklich auf
medizinischer eben gesagt wird der
patienten die patientin braucht jetzt
dass auch diese therapie oder braucht
die eben auch nicht das kann ja auch gut
sein dass man sagt wir wollen jetzt hier
mal keine operationen an sondern wir
wollen die langjährige und
kostenaufwändige konservative therapie
machen und nicht die ganze zeit im
hinterkopf behalten müssen ist das
lukrativ oder macht das sinn und auch
max erzählt mir am ende unseres tages
dass er sich für die zukunft wünschen
würde wenn man aus dem alter kommen muss
also letztendlich die pflege gestärkt
werden brauchen mehr personal eine
bessere ausbildung also 1 1 halten an
verträge die gemacht wurden das heißt
also dienst belastungen reduzieren ich
wünsche mir dass ich meine lieben in ein
krankenhaus bringen kann ohne angst
haben zu müssen dass sie schlecht und zu
wenig versorgt sondern weil ich mir
bewusst bin dass viele patienten hier
liegen und bedürfnisse haben die nicht
von einer person mit 20 betten erfüllt
werden das geht nicht meine recherchen
der tag im krankenhaus haben mir
verdeutlicht mitarbeitende vereine oder
verbände können nur auf das problem
aufmerksam machen dass sich der
langfristig etwas ändert dafür muss die
politik sorgen die sieht das problem
auch dass die edi system wurde in den
letzten jahren verändert und
weiterentwickelt aber an den
arbeitsbedingungen hat sich bis jetzt
nicht möglich etwas verändert wie
niemand reden die situation in deutschen
krankenhäusern war arbeitete er
vielleicht setzen
hedge-fonds oder kennt jemand der dort
arbeitet oder habt ihr vielleicht als
patient oder patienten schon einige
erfahrungen gemacht schreibt uns mal
unten in die kommentare
[Musik]